let's go inside one of the most
remarkable most fascinating and well
most disgusting places on earth and we
mean that in the best sense of the word
let's go inside a termite nest a factory
ventilated by air shafts where termites
produce more termites we're in the
Queen's Chamber the heart of the nest
imagine you're the queen there attended
by millions of sterile worker termites
who live to feed you groom you and carry
your eggs away when you lay them you
aren't acting helpless because you think
you need royal treatment you are
helpless see a termite Queens head is
nearly as small as the rest of the
termites in the colony but she's
rendered immobile by her four-inch
throbbing pulsating egg machine of an
abdomen how many eggs can this body
produce take a guess would you say
hundreds a day maybe I don't know a
thousand a high-performance Queen like
this one can produce well let's do the
math 30,000 eggs in one day times 365
days a year
that's ten million 950,000 eggs times 15
years the life of a queen this body will
crank out 164 million 250,000 eggs in
her lifetime
aha no wonder she needs so many
attendants it's one of their jobs to
carry all those eggs to cells where they
hatch into fragile nips these nips will
grow up to be more workers whose job it
is to continually build and repair the
supply it with food and water and care
for the Queen in this termite factory
the Royal assembly line never shuts down